France's problem is that it doesn't know anymore.
The problem with the European Union is that it is
its total uselessness.
Immigration to Europe.
And so what?
Are the shepherds of the B.
H bilingual?
Marine Le Pen is really 1 woman.
The best drink is water.
Oh you didn't go
flavors.
Parisians are all friends,
friends.
First
singing at the assembly is an act of resistance
with 1 certain plume and 1 brown of courage.
The yellow vests,
it was the last
expression of the French Revolution.
Vladimir Putin's Russia is looking for.
Uh,
if you can look for a little more quietly,
I think it would suit everyone.
The top 28 was
nothing at all the worst doctor in Europe and
there is no ranking in this area
that is now nothing but shadow.